fragen wir mal ein politiker der auch
sehr stilvoll ist philipp amt ist bei
uns von der cdu naja muss man schon
sagen sie sind wirklich immer sehr
schicke kleines er lob von uns an dieser
stelle wie das dem ich danken
wie sehen sie denn das outfit von markus
söder war das angemessen also erstens
braucht markus söder keine stilkritik
von mir und zweitens ich würde auch so
halten ich finde janka vom bayerischen
ministerpräsidenten das passt doch auch
ganz gut und im übrigen gibt es
ministerpräsidenten in deutschland die
unterschiedlich angezogen sind aber
inhaltlich vor allem unterschiedlich gut
aufgestellt sondern da ist markus söder
ganz weit vorne und ich würde sagen der
ist auch bei den themen auch wie er das
medial so macht und wie er das lebt
glaube ich ganz gut aufgestellt und
deswegen verbraucher da keine stil
kritik und ich finde er hat das gestern
gut gemacht und vertritt sein land da
auch mit viel wärme und das ist doch
auch gut ja das kann man sagen es da im
netz hat man sich da ein bisschen lustig
gemacht irgendwie auch zum beispiel
geschrieben so stellt man sich das bei
den simpsons vor dessen besuch in
deutschland alle sind in tracht alle
sind in der lederhose trance musik etc
also da haben wir auch so ein kleiner
wirklich erfüllt und dann kommt der
bayerische ministerpräsident noch im
gang vielleicht sind die beiden ein paar
fragezeichen macht ich glaube ich gar
nicht melden das gehört auch zu den g7
gipfel dazu dass man sich auch ein
bisschen landestypisch inszeniert wenn
man auch daran denkt an die bilder von
barack obama beim letzten g 7 gipfel in
ellmau die sind um die welt gegangen das
alpenpanorama und auch so ein bisschen
na klar die tradition sage ich mal die
es dann mit dem bayrischen verbindet
wenn die bilder um die welt ging es für
deutschland nicht schlecht so ein g 7
gipfel ist immer eine visitenkarte wir
haben ihn ja damals noch im g8 format
auch in meiner heimat in mecklenburg
vorpommern ja mal gehabt den
heiligendamm da gab es natürlich wenig
schuhplattler wenigen krankt aber schöne
bilder der ostsee und ich glaube die
mischung macht's und auch wenn ich jetzt
nicht mitglied im olaf scholz fanclub
des bundestages bin finde ich schon beim
g7-gipfel da geht's auch einfach ums
land und geht es darum dass wir als
deutschland eine gute visitenkarte
abgeben und das tun die bilder im moment
doch eigentlich schon wir reden viel
über den stil der politiker momentan auf
was die first ladys so treiben aber
natürlich im wesentlichen geht es um die
inhalte der sieben großen staats und
regierungschef die da zusammenkommen was
erhoffen sie sich denn von diesem gipfel
na ja es ist natürlich schon jetzt
gerade in dieser zeit des russischen
angriffskrieges ein ganz entscheidender
gipfel das ist das erste mal im prinzip
dass wir ein 7 gipfel auf einem
kontinent haben in dem zeitgleich ein
krieg stattfindet also das ist natürlich
schon eine echte zäsur und es ist
wichtig dass wir jetzt auch sagen das
ist hier nicht nur einen konflikt
zwischen russland und der ukraine und
auch nicht nur einen konflikt zwischen
russland und der europäischen union
sondern die westliche gemeinschaft die
westliche welt auch die demokratien
dieser welt die stehen zusammen das ist
glaube ich das wichtige signal auch
dieses g7 gipfel sind jetzt ist klar man
wird diesen krieg jetzt nicht mit
irgendwie einer gipfelerklärung in
ellmau lösen können ich glaube da würden
wir die erwartungen zu hoch schrauben
wenn wir das tun aber ich glaube
geschlossenheit des westens
geschlossenheit der demokratien
geschlossenheit der g7 das ist schon das
zeichen dass putin jetzt aufhören muss
und sie haben gesagt es wäre eingangs
über markus söder gesprochen haben
lassen sie uns mal aufs inhaltliche
schauen ein inhaltliches thema bei
markus söder habe ich denn noch im ärmel
dem ganzen noch einmal einen blick
werfen auf den twitter account von
markus söder denn er hat alle herzlich
begrüßt als ministerpräsident bayerns
aber wir haben da einmal nachgezählt wir
wollen einmal dieses foto zeigen da
fehlt doch wer da fehlt doch wer mal
drauf die welt zu gast in bayern und da
sehen wir aber gar nicht den gastgeber
dass wir überhaupt nicht olaf scholz und
da fragt man sich im moment mal wir
schauen wir noch mal auf das ganze bild
alle sind drauf aber sind halt nur sechs
und keine sieben
ich würde mal sagen das wird der olaf
scholz schon verstehen da hat er
bestimmt verständnis die muss meine
nicht gesondert in bayern begrüßen als
deutscher
auch das besonders begrüßt 2015 wurde
sie gesondert frist dürfte damit drauf
sein obst jetzt aber komischer zufall
oder scholz nicht das ist doch kein ja
wenn es für olaf scholz zu den
lebensräumen gehört und sohn markus
söder vor zu kommen dann kann man ja
vielleicht noch mal reden aber ich denke
da gibt es auch schlimmeres ich find das
hat der markus söder schon ganz gut
gemacht und die csu macht im übrigen da
ja auch auf social media setzen sind ja
auch gute akzente und dass der urlaub
scholz jetzt nicht hochgejubelt wird es
ja vielleicht auch also voll okay wenn
man da sogar einen seitenhieb zum
kleines ich würde mal waren das gibt es
von anderen seiten auch manchmal und
ansonsten ist der markus söder doch ganz
friedlich ein anderes familienfoto was
gerade um die welt geht es auch eben
gesehen ist das sehr gruppenfoto wasser
ganz gemacht wurde alle sieben staats
und regierungschefs sind drauf und es
ist eine sehr lockere lässige atmosphäre
und dann wird auch gewitzelt ein
bisschen darüber dass man hier auch
irgendwie seine bauchmuskeln zeigen
sollte so wie es putin ja auch mal des
öfteren getan hat ist das der
angemessenen rahmen auch für so späße
für so witze untereinander johnson hängt
hier richtig in den seilen
was getrunken das weiß ich nicht aber
ich glaube für für boris johnson ist
jeder rahmen der richtige rahmen hits zu
machen also insoweit ich fand das
gestern auch gar nicht das gehört auch
ein bierernst darf ich mal dazu dass man
trotzdem auch mein spruch mag ich glaube
der hat boris johnson gestern in dieser
runde so ein bisschen darauf angespielt
ja wir sollten uns am besten so
ablichten lassen wie putin ja beim lachs
gefangen und beim reiten naja gut
immerhin das kann man glaube ich auch
mal machen lockeren spruch kann man
machen und ich glaube ist ja irgendwie
auch bürgernahe das ganze bild wenn
jetzt jetzt nicht jeder irgendwie nur
mit krawatte sondern auch bisschen
lockerheit und gemeinschaft zeigt das
ist ja auch ganz okay und olaf scholz
wenn sie da auch mal ganz locker
natürlich hilft muss man sagen also
urlaub schon lady ist wirklich schwer 1
vers es fällt mir schwer aber es hat
aber er hat aber auch grund zum lächeln
weil wir gesagt deswegen ich hab's ja
eingangs gesagt auch wenn ich jetzt
nicht mit mitglied im scholz fan bin wir
erwarten von ihm dass er deutschland gut
vertritt und das macht er glaube ich
bisher auch ganz ganz okay jetzt kommt
es auf die ergebnisse an und am ende es
ist natürlich so bei ihm kommt jetzt
nicht die herzlichkeit auch wie sie
angela merkel zuletzt hatte das ist halt
so aber auch er als bundeskanzler wird
sich da denk ich mal bemühen dass
deutschland ein gutes bild abgibt und
das ist auch die erwartung und in den
auftakt bildern glaube ich wäre es doch
ist doch besser so als wenn wir da jetzt
lauter traurig dreinblickende männer
gesehen hätte bestimmt auch manchmal
fällt auch in diesem rahmen ist ja immer
wesentlich entspannter als jetzt im
bundestag zum teil komischerweise also
ergibt sich da auf jeden fall immer sehr
offen und humorvoll es ist so also im
deutschen bundestag wird sich
viel zu lachen für ihn auch manchmal
nicht und das ist auch nicht so dass ja
da jetzt ein feuerwerk von witzigen
anekdoten seiner regierungserklärung
sind also da legt er aber immerhin das
haben wir herausgefunden friedrich merz
in gut promoten dann legte er auch mal
redemanuskript beiseite das hat ihm ich
geschadet könnte er öfter mal machen ist
also lockerer olaf scholz ist ja
vielleicht auch gar nicht mal so was
waren einmaliger moment stimmt
relevanter vielen dank am ende sogar
fast mit ein paar kleinen komplimenten
für den bundestag
vielen dank